what would you say is the difference
between
say the early 2000s icml and what we
used to call nips nerms
is there a difference a lot of the
particularly on the machine learning
that was done there
i cmos around that long oh yeah so
iclear is the new conference
newish uh yeah i guess so and i see him
i was
around the 2000. oh html predates that
well i think my most cited icml paper is
from 94. yeah
michael knows this better than me
because of course he's significantly
older than that but the point is yeah
what is the difference what was the
difference between icml and nureps in
the
late 90s early 2000s i don't know what
everyone else's perspective would be but
i had a particular perspective at that
time
which is i felt like icml was more of a
of a computer science
place and that nips nerfs was more of an
engineering place
like the kind of math that happened at
the two places
as a computer scientist i felt more
comfortable with the icml math
and the nurbs people would say that
that's because i'm dumb
and that's such an engineering thing to
say so i agree with that part of it but
i
do a little differently actually i had a
nice conversation with tom dietrich
about this
on twitter just a couple days ago i put
it a little differently which is that
icml was
machine learning done by uh computer
scientists
and nurbs was machine learning done by
computer scientists trying
to impress statisticians
which was weird because it was the same
people at least by the time i started
paying attention
but it just felt very very different and
i think that that perspective of whether
you're trying to impress the
statisticians or you're trying to
impress the programmers is actually very
different and has real impact on
what yeah what you choose to worry about
and what kind of uh
outcomes you come to so i think it
really matters i think computation
statistics is a means to an end it is
not an end in some sense
um and i think that really matters here
in the same way that i don't think
computer science is just engineering or
just science or just math or whatever
but okay so i'd have to now agree
that now we agree on everything yes yes
the important thing here
is that you know my opinions may have
changed but not the fact that i'm right
i think is what
what we just came to right now my
opinions may have changed and not the
fact that i'm wrong
that's right i've lost me i'm not even i
think i lost myself there too but anyway
this happens to us sometimes we're sorry
you